now on the Pearl front I have a few
thoughts
[Music]
Pearl
put on Tick Tock or YouTube recently you
may have seen a few videos of Pearl from
pearly things floating around Pearl is a
content creator who focuses mainly on
the red pill movement and intersectional
Dynamics in dating and marriage and just
for quick reference the web pill is
dating and meeting strategies that are
designed to tackle male oppression and
female hypergamy here are a few of her
Clips in this show I just get a lot of
flack from bitter women honestly because
we talk about things from the men's
point of view a lot of times and we'll
talk about things that specifically
affect men um red pill is just basically
seeing the world is how it is and it's
it's basically like the way they
describe it is blue pill is like the
lies you've been told by society and
like feminism and you take the red pill
and you see the world for how it is
there's a girl on I was on three
different teams so there's a girl on a
team I was on in college yeah and
literally she was a girl next door you
would never know she seemed like the
sweetest chick and I swear to God she
had a a guy she dated her freshman year
of college did him for a month he
cheated he was like around town or
whatever her senior year she was with
the guy that bought her bought her a
house she moved in and I was like yeah
yeah I've told it before and I was at a
party and literally like her and her
body wasn't on Instagram she was a
school teacher good with kids sweet nice
like and literally she was in the
bathroom with the guy from freshman year
at the party her boyfriend came to
um
he bought her house he bought her out
exactly she doesn't respect him and that
was kind of a red pill moment for me
where I was like God damn you would
never know but so what so that's one
girl out of a population of 300 million
are you sick so contrary to popular
belief this 26 year old stunner of a red
pill supermodel is herself unmarried not
particularly religious not a virgin and
seems to be making a good living for
herself with her online content now I'm
going to break this down in two ways
Pearl herself and the content that she
produces on the red pill front do you
remember the scene from The Matrix when
Lawrence Fishburne offers Keanu Reeves a
choice here's a Ghanaian reenactment you
take the blue peel the story ends you
wake up in your bed and believe whatever
you want to believe you take the red
pill you stay in Wonderland and I show
you how deep the rabbit hole goes so in
this the rabbit hole is essentially the
idea that women run the world without
taking responsibility for it and that
their male victims are not permitted to
complain this makes the red pill a
continuous multi-voiced up to the minute
male empowerment movement nestled at the
heart of the so-called manosphere so
it's a network of websites preoccupied
with both men's rights movement and how
to pick up women and blog posts like the
masonry bubble which is quite a long
read basically argues that the Western
world has slowly grown into an
uncivilized society that overvalues
women and undervalues men basically once
you take the red pill you'll finally
realize that female oppression is
non-existent and that men are the ones
getting hard done by even so red pillars
believe that men and women are different
in terms of evolution and thus should
submit to gender roles they believe that
women are better suited to traditional
Lifestyles including getting married and
raising children while men go to work
and provide for the family obviously the
Red Bull movement is huge with loads of
influences and factions but that's
basically the gist of the entire
movement I've been very vocal about the
reptile movement and what I essentially
think is that while it makes a lot of
valid points any movement that's
centered on keeping men and women apart
is not a good thing for society and it's
important to divorce the real issues
from the sensationalist hype that
enriches 19 year old Bugatti owning life
coaches online now on the Pearl front I
have a few thoughts
I hate to be the one to say it but the
messenger doesn't fit the message if I
told you that I had a great money making
scheme and you can make lots and lots of
money from it your first question to me
would be how much money have you made
right or what if I told you that I could
teach you how to raise your kids
wouldn't you want to see how my kids
turned out first what if my children
were a bunch of degenerates anyway the
same logic applies with pearl if she is
such an authority on the things that she
talks about and she's right on them why
is she an unmarried unfeminine
money-making Modern Woman even the way
she makes her points are backwards and
counterproductive look at this clip of a
recent appearance she made on Piers
Morgan talking about women in sport one
another I'm sorry I'm tired of women
whining
the men literally the men fund our
leagues and we will still whine that we
don't get paid enough I think all of the
women should thank the men for funding
our leagues because most of our leagues
would not exist without the men number
one number two I don't hear the man
whining about only fans models getting
paid more than them do whatever men
dominated an industry women will just
complain at the end of the day at the
end of the day at the end of the day
technically she is right but the way
she's making an argument is designed to
be controversial and insightful a normal
person would say something along the
lines of sports viewership works as a
form of entertainment it's not about
what you do it's about how many people
want to see you do it and the more
viewers you attract the more ad Revenue
you generate which is then reflected in
your wages as an athlete the issue of
paying Sports is not about sexism it's
basic economics but no pearl is like
thank the moon for oxygen
strange it's clear what she's trying to
do and she's put a large following doing
it now no one can convince me that this
girl is normal let's be honest other
than the dark resources of the internet
what else can a girl like that gets so
much male attention